- [Interviewer] Wendell.
- Yes.
- Wendell, tell me about your life.
You grew up where?
- [Wendell] I partially grew up
in Los Angeles on the West side.
- [Interviewer] And you grew
up with both your parents?
- [Wendell] No with my mother only.
- [Interviewer] Your mother only?
Where was your dad?
- My father's in Tennessee.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- They separated, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And so,
and how was your childhood generally?
- It was generally, it was good.
It was tight.
You know it was loving from the you know
where the older brother
and a younger sister.
It was a family orientated.
It was really, really loved.
- [Interviewer] And then tell me
about your life after, after that--
- What I did was
after I graduated out of high school
I went to college and
after college ended up getting
married, having four sons,
I started teaching school
for awhile and then
transferred employment
became an electrician.
From that, my mother was sick,
so I came back from the Bay area.
I was, I was in San Jose,
and I came back and just working,
while my mother was alive
and had a major, massive
heart attack twice.
So they had to fix her valves.
And I started veering away from my family
and started hitting the streets of LA
and realizing that this
is where I grew up at.
So I knew a lot of people
and people were starting
to make fast money.
So I enjoyed that.
You know I stepped off into that life
and got into the drugs affiliation.
There was a group of guys that I hung with
that we did not sell
drugs in the neighborhood.
We come downtown and sold in
downtown, faster, quicker,
and no one knows us.
And we would leave every night, you know,
with a pocket full of money.
And then as things got greater
I started staying, staying
one night after another night,
days, weeks, doing the same thing.
And sooner or later I
became my best customer
started using the drugs and drinking
and feeling comfortable
with the homelessness.
But didn't really care because
I had a couple of friends
that we associated affiliated
with and we interacted.
I really, truly didn't care.
We went from hotel to hotel
from the Huntington to the
Frontier, to the Roslyn.
And then I said, we had big money.
Like on the first or the
third, we'd go to the Cecil.
You asked me about stories about the
what I experiencing throughout the years.
It's unbelievable what a
heart and eyes could see.
- [Interviewer] You've been
down here for 30 years, right?
- And yes, I've seen,
I seen a lady that was,
on a seizure in the frontier,
give a man oral sex.
And she had a seizure.
She clamped down
so they call the ambulance.
They brought them both
out there to get a thing
to break her jaw, to release,
to release her at the same time,
the pressure off his penis.
But at the same time I was
standing about four feet
from the ambulance when
they were doing it.
'Cause I was looking and
blood went everywhere.
They had to tie off the
blood for the circulation
from his, where she bit his penis at,
that is the most unbelievable
thing that you could ever see
in your life.
Because if I've seen people
shot, I've seen people stabbed.
I've seen people cut.
I seen a person lose his eye
overusing somebody's pipe.
But to see some man they're hollering
and screaming and they, ambulance is done.
They're not no doctor.
They're doing the best they
can to stop the circulation.
And so he left on the ambulance.
She left on the ambulance.
We saw him about four days later
with a bag on his leg, with the ambulance.
I mean with the hospital uniform on
top of my work, he didn't get a hit.
We were telling him the girl that
that bit your penis.
She going to be getting
out pretty soon if they arrested her.
But I don't think they did.
He says she's upstairs
in Roslyn waiting on me.
It blew my mind.
Why you still affiliating with her?
It so many seen a guy asked
for a pusher to push his pipe
and he pushed his pipe
with, with a coat hanger.
And after he took a hit the guy told him
that he owed him a hit
'cause he used the pusher
and he took the coat hanger
and started stabbing the guy in the neck
and the throat because he
didn't have nothing to give him.
There are many stories that I
could tell you, but you know,
the one that really stays with me
for all my life and
will always stay with me
is the Frontier where we
used to go every morning
to the chicken place,
back on Fifth and Spring.
And it stays open 24 hours a day.
And they had a big pickle jar.
It was empty and people
would put five, 10,
20 dollars in and you circle the floor.
Whatever floor the person
body gets thrown out of
then you can get the money.
If nobody's thrown out that day
that money stays in the jar.
I've won 300 dollars
betting on somebody's life.
I've won nothing on this a lot of times
because I'm guessing the wrong floor.
- [Interviewer] How many bodies
have been thrown off the Frontier?
- I estimate about 40.
- [Interviewer] 40?
- Or more.
- [Interviewer] Yeah I've heard
stories over and over again.
- There has been not from the management
because if it had any faculties,
anything you rent a room.
A lot of them don't have doorknobs.
A lot of them
the sheet ain't been
cleaned, been changed,
and the sheets are
blacker than your shoes.
You got roaches running around
you got rats in the
hallway telling you, hello,
good afternoon, good morning.
The elevator don't work.
You have to take the stairs.
When the process,
going into the Frontier
we always say, you go, you go
on your risk, your own risk.
So you better have somebody with you.
Sometimes I take a guy
with me even though I
there were prostitutes and girls all
in the hallway and all up
and down on every floor.
I always have a guy with
me because I've been there
on the bed and I turned the
bed upside down to just sit.
'Cause it was so nasty and dirty
and get ready to hit the
pipe and the door swing open.
And this guy wants to rob
you for whatever you got.
If they take your shoes
and take your chain,
they take whatever you have
and you can't chase them
down because you don't
know what floor he went to.
And then if he went out the building
nobody sees anything.
That was just experiences at the frontier.
But the great experience that I had
the death was called the Indian alley.
That's located on Fifth and
Los Angeles, towards Main,
right in the middle of
the block is an alley.
And it goes from Fifth Street to Winston.
That's where the Los Angeles
mission use to be located.
And back of the Los
Angeles mission is where
everybody go there to get high.
But at the end of the
alley, down on Winston side,
it's an Indian section, had a building.
If you didn't get robbed in the process of
behind the L.A. mission,
if you go there by the Indian alley,
you're definitely going to get robbed
and they're gonna take everything.
And I mean, literally
everything, pants, shoes, shirt,
you know, especially your drugs.
So everybody would walk
down Los Angeles street
and then come in, come in on Fifth Street.
Because if you go down Winston
and go into the alley, you know,
you're going to get robbed.
They never come down into
the middle of the alley
but they just be waiting
for people to take
take their risks and walk through there.
I've seen it.
The Indians have machetes.
All we had was just iron sticks
and little pipes or
milk crate or something.
And we sit up and get high and sell drugs.
But they were down there
doing strong arm robberies
and sometimes cutting people.
And if you call the police
the police would tell you
it's not my area, it's not my area,
it's not my district,
they wouldn't go down Indian alley.
They knew what was happening.
They knew that the Los Angeles
mission would be breakfast,
lunch, and dinner.
And after dinner time
that alley becomes like a rock concert.
You'll see the lighters flashing
and you'll see the people
interacting, dancing,
and drugging, but never
go down on the other side.
And they sit there and I
mean, groups of them, 10, 15,
20 Indians, pure Indians, American Indian,
they be sitting there
drinking their alcohol
and shooting up their heroine.
And they looking for somebody
because they don't have any money.
And they were crying
to get the dollar bill
best way they could.
That is my greatest experience.
But throughout my experiences in
in skid row was the lady told me to,
she told me that once
you come into my place
and I was looking for
where she was talking about
and she had a porter
potty with carpet on it
shag carpet had the radio
television set up in there
and she wants you to come into
a porty party to have sex.
And the smell
by itself would just knock
your socks off, you know,
because it's unbelievable.
- [Interviewer] She was
using it as an office for--
- For business, sexual favors, yes.
And she used to do that.
Then she turned around and
she made three porty potties,
they were all together lined up
on Sixth Street and they
were on Sixth and St. Julian
and they would line up
going towards Wall Street.
And it'd be about 10 of them lined up
and she, the first three were hers,
the first three were that
you can rent them out
or you could use it for, with her.
- [Interviewer] And make some money?
- And make some, yeah.
And then she, she rented them out.
She that changed at the time of
we had a mayor coming down through a tour
through skid row and she
asked him, do you want a date?
And he was dressed in
his normal, you know,
Levi's and t-shirt okay.
Not before Garcetti.
Okay, and he, that same
night, the following day,
they removed all the porter
potties out of skid row.
Because of that.
I've seen guys that do unbelievable,
students from USC college come downtown
and go into any of those
stores on Broadway.
And they come out, they
lost their bicycles.
That's a hobby that is
still going on today.
- [Interviewer] It happens
on an hourly basis.
- I beg your pardon?
- [Interviewer] It happens
on an hourly basis.
- That is a, that is a basic survival kit.
We call it the survival
kit when you can't hustle
and you can't get nothing else
go up on Broadway, Spring,
or Hill, snatch a bicycle
and bring it down here.
Someone will buy it.
Yes that is a--
- [Interviewer] So your
path has been interesting.
You were a crack addict
and a gang member,
eventually what happened?
- What happened was I was,
I was joining
with several brothers that
were in the gang activity.
I came to my senses.
I was drunk and I had a four day binge.
And I was, I mean,
I just left a couple of
chicks freaking or whatever.
And I came on Fifth Street
staggering and the body
wanted to shut down.
So I laid down,
literally laid down on the sidewalk
and I'm trying to get me some sleep.
And to the day, I don't
know who the guy was,
but I do know one thing,
he saved my life with the higher power
but he kicked me in my
ribs and he kicked me
on my leg and I was
trying my best to get up.
And when he called me
a no good motherfucker,
you're an asshole,
you need to get the outta here,
get away from the front of this building,
I rolled over and started
throwing up in the street,
and I'm on the curb laying down.
And he was standing over, cursing me.
I stopped throwing up
and I sit up and I asked
the man above
if you take this from me, I'll serve you.
Whatever it is, take it from me.
I had, I have turned my
heart was already hard,
and that was a WDC.
That means we don't care.
Okay I didn't care about
the police department.
I didn't care about the system.
I didn't care about anything.
I was the only caring about my life.
I didn't care about my
children or anything.
I just broke them out of
my brain, don't even exist.
And in the process of that 24 hours,
I got up and went around
the corner on Winston
and sit on a cardboard box
asking myself how stupid can you be?
And at the same time, I said,
just give me one more, one more try.
And I guarantee you
I guarantee you with the breath I breathe,
I would serve you.
A couple of days later, I go
into St. Vincent CARNA manner.
I stayed there
about six months inside,
never went outside.
I was still evaluating my
life, getting myself together.
At that time, I went from
my first walk outside,
and I noticed that this might be skid row.
And it might be a special
community, but it is a community.
And I said I'm going to
do my best to make it
a community instead of a wayside.
And from people like I
have done made mistakes
and errors that you shouldn't be making.
I end up not using any
detox with me, myself.
I searched myself every day to make sure
that I've taken my first
foot and my last foot
in a positive note, I realized
that I have to do something.
So I just started to move walk around.
When my eyes were focusing
on the dollar bill prior
to this, how can I hustle?
How can I NYPLI?
How can I get some money?
Now my eyes is completely changed the lane
and I'm focusing on
how can I help someone?
How can I take someone's life,
reform them and change them?
I don't want them to be like me
but I want them to be
best the best they can be.
I didn't know.
So I walked through skid row,
walking through skid row,
and I came back to the park
and I was leaning against the fence.
And the guy walked up to me and said
where can I take a shower?
And I said, you need more
than a shower, brother.
He said yeah well I've been on a train
and I've been, and I've made
it down there on skid row.
And I didn't, I got to change my pants.
'Cause I shitted in my pants.
I said, well, you need more than a shower.
And I told him to go across the street
and see if they give you a shower
or you might have to go down
to the midnight or the union
but somebody will give you a shower.
And that's when I realized that I could be
a beacon of light for people.
So I set up a table
didn't know what I was doing at first,
setting up a table, talking to people,
asking them, how can I help you?
A lot of people at that time
were dragging about give
me a dollar bill, you know,
give me a cigarette, they
was trying to hustle me.
I then is tried to molding
almost a year ago by
and I was over at Grand Central
Market, just sitting there.
And I learned the hustle about
the Grand Central Market is
that if you get there between
the hours of five and six
they getting ready to close down,
all that leftover food,
they sell dirt cheap.
You know, normally what they
would pay for five dollars,
you only pay 50 cents or a dollar.
They just wanted out of the tray.
So I used to go get lasagna
or chicken, you know,
I'm just sitting there, I
got three plates right here,
and I'm just grubbing, you know?
And I ain't even pay two dollars.
I'm just grubbing at myself up.
And this woman was sitting right behind me
and she said she represent, she
was talking to another lady.
She represents skid row
and they got to go voting
on some property that they want to convert
over to start building construction.
And I looked back
and I see this Caucasian lady, up in age,
and I asked her, I said,
I said, where do you stay?
She said, I stay in Bunker Hill.
And I said oh that's
on the other side of Grand
Central Market right there.
She says, yes.
I said, when's the last
time you'd been to skid row?
She says, I've never.
I said, well,
why are you voting for skid row?
I'm on the downtown executive board
of downtown neighborhood council.
And I just kept eating.
And then my spirit says, hey,
maybe I need to inquire about that.
So what I did 14 years ago, I went,
and vote to the voting poll,
found out about the procedure,
put my name in a ballot,
wrote a little story about myself
and I was elected by
the peers of skid row.
There was the largest
turnout they ever had.
I just got elected again.
Last year to a 2200 people
voted for me that are homeless
that live in skid row
but walked all the way to
to Seventh and Flower to
vote, or caught the bus.
But 2200 people took the
initiative to do that.
When I became a downtown
neighborhood council
the first thing I did was
to make them recognize
that that we are somebody
and no matter what the situation is,
if you shake your tree
you will find somebody in
your family that's homeless.
So if don't treat the
one that you don't know
but you definitely not
treating the one you do know.
So why don't you treat everybody the same?
So, and that means giving respect.
So I intervene and walking,
then I realized that we didn't
have no handicap crosswalks.
Most of the signal lights
were at three minutes,
the street lights for a very poor,
and a lot of blind spots
throughout the last four years.
I've met with different
agencies throughout the city
for street maintenance
to street construction.
And now right now I can literally say
that in the 40 blocks of skid row
I think we got 37 blocks covered
with handicap crosswalks.
All the lights in skid
row has been adjusted
to new paper, new lighting.
So there's no blind spots
at all throughout the area.
But the most important thing is
that people are being recognized
that it is a problem in homelessness.
No one graduated out
of high school said they
want to be homeless.
They and even myself went through
that part of mental health
where you get depressed,
things you used to have,
you don't have no more.
Your family that you though got your back
don't have your back.
And the friend said, the call
friends, they ignore you.
You mind become a concrete
barrier where you blocked
in and they say mental health.
I say, it's just a form of changing.
And you have to re change
just like a child is
being taught how to walk,
you have to be retaught how to live again
and appreciate housing.
Appreciate the things
that you used to have.
You have more respect for
them now in the present day.
- [Interviewer] You have to love yourself.
- Yeah you have to
diligently love yourself.
Yes.
- [Interviewer] That's
what I see a lot from a lot
of the people I talk to, you
just don't value yourself.
- That's right.
They value others
but don't take the time
out to value their self.
- [Interviewer] Yeah I mean
they're almost hell bent
on making sure they
don't value themselves,
they just don't feel they deserve it.
- It's a, it's a guard that you put up,
and I, some people say mental health.
When you see individual yelling
and screaming or whatever
acting up real loud, no,
it's nothing wrong with
them being in mental health.
They just don't want to be bothered.
They don't want to no interaction
no communication just leave me alone
and let me do what I do.
Love is the greatest key of it all.
If you learn how to love
yourself, and you realize that,
that there are rules and boundaries
and everything we do in life.
But when you realize that all
of this laws that are set
in front of us are myths.
If you don't take the
time out to love yourself
because when you love yourself,
you appreciate the law.
I'm not cross jaywalking.
You appreciate the law.
I'm not messing with drugs.
You appreciate the, say excuse me.
- [Interviewer] All kinds of other things
will fall into place--
- That is correct.
- [Interviewer] Including
how, how you treat others.
- That is very correct.
- [Interviewer] Especially now.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Excellent, Wendell,
thank you so much for talking to me.
Your story is incredible.
- No, I don't know.
I just know that I'm a beacon of light
and nothing more important is
to see someone get a door key.
I have last year, I received
award from the city.
Well several rewards I've received
from danger man award,
I'm in the Afro-American
museum for that award.
I have received an award for the city
for doing got 241 people housed last year
with no help from other agencies.
Just me calling landlords,
me calling owners,
say take a chance for someone,
give an opportunity for a person
that that is in skid row
wants to change their life.
They want a fresh start.
The greatest one that I just went
through the experience
is the lady Miss Glass.
We got her an apartment in the process
of getting in her one bedroom apartment,
she turned right around and
the apartment was furnished.
And I thought it was lovely.
I looked at it.
I saw it was great,
better than what I got.
I mean with a half kitchen counter.
It was clean of marble floor.
I mean, wooden floor, buffing and shining,
big old couch in the living room.
The landlord calls me
and tells me Wendell,
you need to come over right away.
I thought she was just
maybe throwing a tantrum.
Maybe she was cussing someone out
or maybe she's just doing her thing.
I get over there
and all the furniture that
was supposed to be in furnace
in the unit, even a brand
new bed and a bed frame,
was outside, down the
side of her building.
And I knock on the door
and I asked her what's up.
She told me nothing.
You want to come in.
And I was getting ready
to come in to talk to her.
And I see this big old tent
in the living room floor.
And I said, I can't go in there.
I said, why don't you come
outside and let's talk.
So I told the landlord to give me a
give me a little space for a minute.
Let me talk to her.
And I explained to her about
the rules of the lease.
These property, the furniture
it belongs to the owner,
and we're putting it in your unit.
And if you don't want it in your unit
you need to get into contact
with them and let them move it.
Since you moved it out, you
have your own car garage,
and you, but you don't have a car.
Why don't you put that
furniture in the garage?
And as you start to feel comfortable
start moving it back in.
But you know
what you need to do is to
take that tent down, girl.
You know, she told me I
can't sleep without the tent.
I says, maybe downsize, just take a look,
just think about it.
I'm not asking you to do anything
that you can't do yourself,
just think about it.
Right now it's been almost two months
and the tent is still up in the room,
but the bed is back in there.
- [Interviewer] You have to get use to--
- So see, and that's what I'm working,
that really amazed me.
- [Interviewer] Alright Wendell,
thank you very much for talking to me.
Good luck with everything.
- Thank you very much.
I'm glad,
I'm glad I'm able to help somebody.